hi and welcome to the session on modern
Enterprise Java from the ground up and
yeah I'm very happy to talk about this
topic here from modern enterprise Java
whether there is such a thing so my name
is Sebastian I'm born and raised in
Munich Germany and I work for this
company called IBM and I have a lot of
well background in Java in in general
Enterprise Java in particular and
enterprise software so I've been in
consultant than doing a lot of things
there and what I want to show you in
this talk and what the motivation is is
basically to somewhat show you a restart
for things related to enterprise Java
for if you heard of j2ee of Java EE and
all that story to show you how modern
enterprise projects for cloud native
micro services are being built up from
scratch
so if you have already a history in you
know things related to j2ee or java ee
you might as well you know forget a lot
of things because there's a lot of
history involved right there and what I
want to show you is a modern approach
best practices how to do that and I
don't know about you but I think slides
are mostly kind of boring so I will show
mostly live coding and live demos
because I think that's just more
interesting to watch and especially
after you know lunch if I would tell you
the story how we came here with natchok
RTE and things like that you would
immediately fall asleep so I don't want
to bore you with that what I want to
show you is just two things that you
might heard of two technologies and I'm
gonna actually use them both one is
called - Carta EE sounds very much like
Java EE and that is actually the
successor of Java EE so now Jakarta is
open source and an open source
foundation under the Eclipse Foundation
and the most important thing is Java EE
or Jakarta EE you could wrote a replace
that what I want to focus on are the
quote unquote good parts at least
according to me these are the
technologies that you want to care about
why because Java EE or Jakarta
traditionally includes a lot of lot of
lot of things because of a long history
so there are many technologies that you
certainly don't want to use
to want to look at because of all
everything that is being supported out
of being backwards compatible but what
we do want to look at here is a small
list of that zdi you might have heard of
this very powerful technology for
injection and for building up components
Jax arrests we're gonna have a look at
that restful Web Services how to use it
Jason P Jason B I'm pretty sure you're
familiar with with these terms JP a JT a
for transactions EJB but only in the
latest version version 3 not the old
stuff so it should be includes some
somewhat reasonable technology that is
still useful and then a few other things
now the second thing that I will use and
show you is technology called eclipse
micro profile which I will use as
somewhat an extension for modern cloud
native based workloads and while
technology that is needed there so good
parts of micro profile and the
interesting thing is it's actually based
on the same technology so it's very much
related is that in comes with a few more
old technologies that are helpful for us
if we think of traditional enterprise
systems we might miss you know a few
things like for example metrics how to
build fault tolerance and you know a few
api's to just make our life simpler so
I'm gonna use some stuff right there and
other than that let's just start right
away and I'm gonna show you a few best
practices that you might have seen or
might have not seen so for example this
is a maven project whoever uses maven to
build enterprise projects most of you I
would assume yes and that part is
already quite important because I care a
lot of keeping that simple as a best
practice there are a lot of maven
conventions out there that can be used
right away that most developers even
aware of so they would you know redefine
things and redefine plug-in structures
and configuration that's actually not
needed because maven does a lot of
things very correctly very well just out
of the box without changing anything so
what I will use I use thin deployment
artifacts and there's a reason for that
that I will
tell you a little bit later and I will
use just two dependencies one is called
Jakarta that's the modern 2-car de 8 and
one is called Eclipse micro profile
that's it important thing that you see
here provided scope for these
dependencies so that means they don't
end up in whatever you're building right
they don't end up in the Diploma
artifact and everything else you see
there is actually just test thing so
that's already an important thing I
don't want to include you know stuff
then I don't really want to have in my
application only what's required only
these provided dependencies everything
else is just there for test purposes and
then what I have is the configuration of
my java built i use java 12 just because
I'm brave so that's a it's not even the
latest one Java 13 would be you know
latest version right so I could update
that that is also thing other than that
I don't use any you know plugins or
configuration here this is just we
defined some versions and that's about
it right and then the application is
called coffee shop just because I like
coffee and what about you is just real
quick a walk through through the Jakarta
application I have here which we then
got a live code and enhance a little bit
so imagine I want to build up an
application where I can order some
coffee right it's after lunch at a
conference you want to place an order
for coffee right and that means well
we're gonna build an application that we
can communicate with via rest so you
probably have seen that code these api's
this is called orders resource that is
going to be an HTTP resource and the
rest resource if you want that is
accessible via some URL path slash
orders and communicates with while
resources data represented as JSON right
so I could for example a issue so made
should be get to get some orders right
or some pose to post some orders to
order some coffee
which already uses quite some enterprise
api's so the nice story about that is
it's very declarative here I just write
some Java code right and then I sprinkle
some annotations on it and that already
makes a lot of things happen
so that is gonna be an HTTP handler
which a post request being coming in
into the system and this is being ended
up in that method and then I have some
Java class just a coffee order which
just because it's defined within a
Jack's rest resource will be
deserialized from json and this was just
my business component a coffee order
with some you know that's the order that
I place I can order some different
coffees like you know expresso latte or
whatever and well that's pretty much it
and then I have a business component
that I that I call a coffee shop that
just well talks to the backend that
stores the coffee order for me in memory
okay whatever
and that's pretty much it for that use
case so that creates some coffee
okay now enough talking let's see this
in action let's see what that does and
now for the best practice of building
this project how would it build this
first of all that's a maven project so I
will build this using maven and I call
maven clean package or I could also call
just maven package to build this and now
the first important thing is this has to
build real quick so well that's too slow
let's do this again maybe the computer
is under load for seconds or less to
three seconds that would be ideal
well anyway but at least fast enough you
know to build your project in a modern
way any plugin configuration you add or
any sophisticated tests the cycles just
makes it unnecessarily slow we will talk
about tests a little bit in a second but
that is important that it already builds
things very quickly
another thing is because of these thin
deployment artifacts our war file that
we produce is tiny right it only
contains the classes we can have a look
the classes that we include that we
compile you know the classes that are
part of our project nothing else why
because our enterprise runtime includes
the implementation we don't hip an
implementation and we don't build the
implementation to a binary because also
I believe it doesn't really make sense
because we have to build this binary
many many many times a day
and you know each time 99% of the code
that we ship wouldn't change right so we
want to separate the implementation from
our business logic so in this case we
have now a thin diploma artifact that we
could target that we could deploy so now
if you know about you know traditional
EU runtimes we could go and download
some runtime from some website or
whatever or in this case I use docker
containers so I will deploy this later
on in a darker approach docker files you
probably have seen these are that's also
very interesting already how we can
build up a best practice for docker
files of otoko creating docker images
I built this thin deployment artifact
this war file for a reason first of all
it's fast to build my maven build is
real quick because I don't have to copy
a lot of megabytes around and it really
makes sense for that docker approach why
docker comes with a few enhancements a
few optimizations on the caching level
it's being built on what is called a
copy-on-write filesystem and it only
well points it references to changes in
all the file system to diffs pretty much
like git works and it will only apply
these changes and transfer changes that
are actually have been made right so for
example that means if this base image
contains a lot of you know megabytes of
stuff and these two files are very tiny
then each and every time I transfer I
transmit something the changes are
actually tiny as well I don't transfer a
lot of things because most of it might
already be existent you know on the
other machine I can show you this in
action in a second so the whole thing I
built with my docker image is well
everything that my application needs in
order to live in order to run so in this
case I include some runtime open Liberty
I'll show you this on the website as
well that is an open source runtime that
is originally based on WebSphere Liberty
has been open source there's a
commercial support available for that
and this is what I use together with
Java 12 to run my software ok
and then I will have some tiny
configuration as well and then I built
us for my coffee shop ok enough talking
let's finally do this docker build let's
call this coffee shop built this
application again is tiny
for all the changes that I make and it
builds fast so then we can run this
locally docker run into a tea coffee
shop right or how did I call it coffee
shop time no coffee shop let's call this
with a name that's also best practice
for docker always put in labels coffee
shop temp right coffee shop temp run
this and while this is running I can
show you another thing so if I just
built my my image I can do this again
builds with actually a docker hub named
coffee shop temp why because then I can
docker push and pull my image and now
depending on a network what you will see
I now will do a darker push which is an
image that has you know hundreds of
megabytes I think 400 and something
including the runtime including the JDK
but even over a somewhat okayish
conference network it's doable
wide you saw it actually only pushed a
few kilobytes why because the diff is
tiny the diff my Java classes that I
included in my BA file is very very
small in each and every time I make a
new build and I shipped the stalker
image
it's a tiny change it's just kilobyte
that I transmitted and I kid you not I
used my phone tethering somewhere in the
middle of nowhere and they used in
airplane Wi-Fi to push docker containers
docker images before if you have such an
approach it works right you're just
pushing a few kilobyte which is not a
big deal so that works here there's a
very nice approach for that it just
leverages that principle and now finally
we can have a look at this coffee shop
example coffee shop slash orders coffee
shop is the name of the application and
then we can it should be get the list of
coffee orders which is well an empty
JSON array right so there is no order in
a system that's not really surprising
but now let's finally create some order
right we want to see this in action okay
what we do we gonna post some JSON to
this resource right this is what you saw
in the code we actually want to post a
coffee order here in the JSON
representation so how does this look
well we need at least the type for the
coffee order which would say I want to
order an espresso if that's all right
and then well hopefully if we're lucky
that's good news 201 created the order
has been created in the system and I can
actually now have a look at the list of
my coffee orders and I will see okay
great there's an espresso there good
works okay that's actually not what I
wanted to show you um that is just you
know a nicer hello world example of a
JSON response that I posted here but now
what I can do I can change some things
and I especially want to introduce some
you know micro profile api's so I want
to introduce you know a few api's that
are required for modern runtimes so the
dad has already run that is already
something that I can run in you know a
docker container I can run this and
rerun this now locally and you know in
order to perform some actions here now
what I will do I will actually change
some stuff and live code something here
and then what I would need to do so who
have you attended my previous session
earlier today of you okay that's good
not too many because then I don't spoil
too much what I was using there already
was an approach to make these changes a
little bit faster so assuming I change
some code here what would I need to do
in order to reflect the changes while I
would need to rebuild my project right
using maven what I did before and at
least rebuild the docker image right
docker built and then I would need to
restart my docker container right docker
run because I cannot hot-swap running
containers I need to start that again
and then I have to change its being
reflected what else I can do what I will
show you here is an approach that
actually runs maybe with Liberty with a
plugin that allows me for us more
sophisticated development workflow so
now the sounds like it's a little bit
against the principle that
say keep the Maven workflow as simple as
possible but at least this plugin
doesn't add anything to the normal build
if I say maven package it's actually not
executed that's a good thing because I
want to keep my maven build simple but
if I say Liberty and call on Def what I
just called here then what it will do it
will start up a development mode of my
open Liberty runtime which is a little
bit different to what I would run in my
docker image but it comes with a nice
feature that it actually allows me to
change things on the fly and add code
and change code and apply that
immediately so what does it mean
I now curl let's call this again and now
we deployed my application so I can call
it again I get my coffee orders now it's
empty okay fine I could create some
coffee orders now I have an order in the
system again so it works right the same
application that has been deployed but
now I can add some more features and
what I will show you is let's start with
health checks I will show you my micro
profile API micro profile health which
allows me to add well some health checks
and why what mica profile does it just
adds some api's of well features and
concerns we need for modern micro
services that we then have don't have to
code ourselves right so if for example I
want to add some health check endpoint
then I would need to write some Jack's
rest a class or whatever and what I can
do here I can just add some health
checking here which is an API that now
you see it in the package it comes from
micro profile micro profile health ok
the nice story is that API isn't
compatible with well with Java
Enterprise so what I can do call this
coffee shop I now add a health check for
my application that just you know it's
very simple it just says yes as soon as
the application is deployed and so
called ready it will add this CDI
component and then says ok I'm ready
you could add all kinds of you know
custom checks you can say please check
the database check an external system
whether my application is up and running
and then it will just tell you
now the nice thing is I could now
restart my application and show you how
that works and then you would see that
under curl localhost / health I see
something available the slash health is
by the way a convention by micro profile
health so it will show you oh one status
see this oh I need to activate it sorry
once that is the case it might show you
some stuff here so what I can do this is
let's remove this for a second
this is my server configuration an XML
for the OP Liberty but don't worry it
doesn't get much bigger than that it
includes the feature that I want to
include in my runtime and that is
already an optimization I could say
please include the whole of Java EE
include everything in micro profile but
why I lists and features individually is
just an optimization that it loads
faster right because it loads less stuff
and what I can add here is I can add
micro profile health and that is already
a feature of this plug-in that is
running it actually will inspect the
features that I need in what's going on
here and now it works in my application
and then it will hot reload whatever I
have in my code and now it just added
the slash health endpoint for the health
check because I added this health check
component and then it will says oh now I
have a new check here it says coffee
shop and it's up and running now I have
two features available here first of all
I can add runtime features on the fly
and the second much more interesting I
can actually add code and change code
here on the fly so for example I can say
in my health check please add some data
hello world or hello Ora def right what
it will do it will haunt reload my
application and immediately see the
changes in my code in general in the
whole application so this is specific to
that feature that I just added but what
it will do it will very quickly and you
know less than half a second or at least
less than a second update the
application with just well compiling
that class and swapping the class in the
running process
so for me it's very very fast to just
you know change some stuff in my
application while I'm coding this is
really really efficient alright but what
I actually want to show you is some
features in micro profiles so I just
that was micro profile health check
which is an API to do some health
checking that you know then you would
use for your taco containers or if you
use kubernetes I'll show you that in a
second as well it's helpful to you know
easily add health checks here something
else config injectable configuration
there is micro profile config that has
also shipped with micro profile that I
can use here as well because my runtime
supports that I can use this annotation
at config property and then for example
say oh please
annotate and inject the configuration
that you find by some you know key by
some configuration key for example
version so I can say not short but
string include a string version for
example and then you know at this
version to my health check here version
alright and then in this case I will
output and emit this version as a
convict um here as well and once that is
up and running
of course I what did I forget forget to
add the feature and again this is just
an optimization I could say please add
everything in micro profile and that
would be a simple about this then well
starts upload blue faster so in this
case not well really plan an application
feature here that I can use I can also
have a programmatic lookup of the
configuration depending on what you do
in the code right not just the
declarative approach of injecting it
here but also you know more
sophisticated approach for that let's
live code a little bit more assuming we
have our coffee a coffee order do we
have some order in the system let's have
a look no let's create some let's add
some more information for the order the
coffee order here comes with a few
things like you know a coffee type
espresso a status let's add some price
right let's add some price here assuming
we have our coffee order wizard we want
to add some
information so assuming we have a status
and then we add some private you know
double price by the way never use
floating points in real life to reflect
price information right don't do this at
home and let's add some getters and
setters soups for the price so let's
include the price in the coffee order
and then of course the user should not
specify the price right that should be
specified by the configuration obviously
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
deploy this example with our business
component to say okay now let's update
here something in the price and I want
to have a price calculator so I'm just
writing a new class price calculator
that is going to calculate the price so
let's say we have something like a
public double calculate price for a
coffee order right something like this
and then now depending on the order type
I want to calculate a price and probably
you have already seen I want to
calculate that price I don't know which
currency I used here as an example so
this will be a little bit expensive and
should we do the Swedish Krona right for
a coffee I don't know I already winners
eggs expensive in general but that would
be a little bit crazy so anyway we can
change that but that means we want to
look up the price depending on the order
type right so depending on the coffee
type of course we want to say for
example return and then you know get
configured price something like this for
the type which then will be well
implemented here and now that is the
configure programmatic lookup we can
have for example working we can have a
look at the configure conflict provider
we can say oh now please give me the
conflict and now do something like well
give me a value for a specific key right
and then the key will be for example
computed on the fly so we have something
like coffee dot prices dot well type of
it right so let's say coffee dot prices
dots
the type of the name to lowercase
something like this right so let's have
this and let's look up the type should
be a double right so I'm assuming that
as you know correct now this is all done
programmatically it's not that it's not
that convenient as doing the injection
part but now it's of course much more
flexible and powerful I can inject the
configuration here can even say get some
optional value if it's not available
have some default and so on and so forth
but now I can already use this
components or what I would do of course
I would inject my press calculator right
so and use this down there so let's say
or the set price - well whatever I
calculate here right calculate price for
the order by the way I'm relying on you
that I don't make any mistakes
is it correct yes no maybe yes okay
perfect somebody believes him and what I
do let's really apply this and then see
whether it works so order well it's
empty let's create some espresso so
coffee has been created right great and
now let's have a look whether that works
with curl and it says oh great it's now
well way too expensive right that is an
espresso 480 kronor
okay let's change this a little bit that
is too crazy now help me what is a good
price for an espresso 20 I think outside
there's a coffee shop and they had like
25 or something like that which i think
is a reasonable price let's make the
other ones 25 and the espresso 20 I
think that's a good good price and then
again you saw the configuration will
also reload so we can do this and let's
now order some latte and the newly
deployed application and the latte
should yes now be 25 kronor that's a
little bit more reasonable ok then we
get our reasonably priced latte once we
reload that right so that is a feature
to show micro profile config on a
programmatic approach we can do the
programmatic lookup of our config
sources and then inject these values
this is just you know much much more
convenient than coding that ourselves
right because before this micro profile
config what would we have to do we had
use cd-i features to for example use you
know something like a CD I produce a
method and then doing the lookup in the
property file ourselves it's not rocket
science it's like in a few lines of code
to read from the property file or from
an environment variable but it's just
much more effort that if you do it
yourself another feature which is a
little bit more helpful if for example
you have some monitoring let's have a
look at micro profile metrics so micro
profile metrics what that includes are
some metrics out-of-the-box for example
micro profile metrics include well some
technical metrics for my application
that might already be interesting so
under the slash under the path slash
metrics I will find some metrics that I
typically well my open Liberty says
these metrics are actually not for
everybody so I will just you know make
them only accessible via HTTP or is it
forbidden and then you know I would need
to use HTTPS or I just say you know MP
metrics authentication Falls because now
for my you know debug example I really
don't care
Falls if I can type and then I can have
the same thing again I will just read it
a configuration and reload and now this
looks a little bit weird this is a plain
text format that is called Prometheus
the Prometheus metrics format that well
will be scraped in a you know cloud
native example in my kubernetes cluster
by a Prometheus instance which then
Prometheus is a time series database
which then will be stored in a time
series database and can be you know
displayed in some fancy dashboards and
then I see you know the memory
consumption or some JVM details here
what is the memory what is the CPU
garbage collection and all kinds of
things that I could display ok this
might be helpful for operations so it
already includes a lot of things out of
the box that I don't have to configure
which is good but these metrics are
particularly interesting if I can
include some business related metrics
right so rather than just saying what is
the transaction rate what is the memory
whatever of my application I want to say
okay how many orders have have been
placed how many coffee was ordered how
many you know how much money did we
learn today how much revenue we have or
whatever so what I also can do I can use
this metrics API for you know as an API
in Java code I can add my own custom
metrics right I can say please add a
counter for all the coffee orders and
then calculate the prices something like
that per day right and omit that as well
which from a business perspective is of
course much more valuable so for example
what I could say in my business
component coffee shop I could let's say
inject some metric that I then
programmatically you know modifies so I
say now we just got some order now
please increase it by the coffee price
or whatever or in this case you know
there are many examples available I
could either programmatically inject a
metric or I do that's the simplest
example i annotate a method with
accounted that literally you know counts
the method invocations so in this case
that's quite straightforward I could say
I just count the number of or that
coffees right it was already some might
be quite helpful how many coffees have
been ordered today
and now if I redeploy this then I'd say
for example I want to post and create
some new coffee one two three and then I
go back to my metric and say oh great
now I have a new counter being included
in this example and that is already you
know showing me a three coffee right so
that is there out-of-the-box it's
included in that metrics and it's you
know very simple to use
I could inject my own counter and
increase it I couldn't have a histogram
and some a gauge some other types and
things like that what is included in
this API so again just much more helpful
than writing all of that yourself and
these are just a few few examples where
it helps you to have this combination of
you know this micro profile api's and
turn more traditional Java EE so you can
have a look at that there are many many
many more examples that I could show you
in that time what else I would like to
show you is just some
example how that whole thing runs in a
cloud environment so what I have here is
some kubernetes example right so we want
to order some coffee that actually runs
in a more production like setting and
you probably well kubernetes versety
website who have used using kubernetes
or anything similar like a container
orchestration nobody oh well whew yeah
at least so maybe you had a look at the
this technology already or that
especially from experience where most of
the ecosystem is moving to like you know
to more these cloud environments we have
containers we have containerized
environments and that is just the next
step a technology that orchestrates
these workloads for us right it's just
another way of using an open-source
technology for things we otherwise have
to do ourselves right a lot of
enterprises have written their own
frameworks their own technology how to
run stuff in production right how to run
their VMs how maybe to run containers
and that is just a more sophisticated
set of proven open source technology
originally developed by Google has been
open sourced many years ago and what you
can do while you can use a Cuban Eddie's
to basically run that you know let's say
production or staging environment here
what I have I have if the Wi-Fi works I
have a kubernetes cluster that runs on
the IBM cloud manage kubernetes service
that as you can see now is empty if you
might have seen that before
queue control is a command line tool to
basically talk to my kubernetes cluster
so it doesn't run any applications now
control pots pots as a workload like you
know a running container and it says
well empty what I can do I can actually
deploy something now and what I just did
is what I can show you these yellow
files so you might have had a look at
this that is basically a s code
description how my environment should
look like so very similar to the idea
what I had with docker files
docker files is an infrastructure as
code example of how I want to define
stuff in a declarative approach right i
defined a target state as code i put
that into the version control next to my
source code and this is now further
specifying how the whole environment
looks like right not just one instance
but you know the whole services that I
have I have some load balancer service
here for my coffee shop I have my
deployments which is you know one
version of the instance so I could
change that to two or three I could
increase the number of instances and now
if I just take these files and apply
them throw them against my cluster then
it will automatically create some
resources for me so then when I say oh
please the target state should be one
instance of my coffee shop well then it
will go and take and deploy one instance
of the coffee shop deployment right and
that just runs my you know a default
Java EE plus micro profile application
and runs that on a cloud and it will
include you know and you make use of
some health checking so it will ask the
health check hey are you already ready
to serve some traffic and to do
something meaningful and now that is the
case ok great now I can go against my
cluster and find out the IP address of
my cluster and say ok where's my coffee
shop orders so same thing that I just
had and this is now using an actual IP
address of my kubernetes cluster of
where I just deployed my application to
so you see that also enables me to just
you know ship software so much faster by
having some declarative approaches as
code and then just roll them out as you
go in a you know very sophisticated same
way let's order some coffee here that is
basically being created on the cloud
let's order some espresso and now that
is being created ok great let's have a
look that is the created coffee order in
my cloud environment that I just
deployed to kubernetes and this is done
a workflow where you know quite easily I
can write some things I can build my
application using maven I can build my
docker images and then deploy it to for
example an environment which of course
would be made as part of an
see icd pipeline then so as some key
takeaways the nice story about this
combination of a modern Enterprise Java
is that we use known technologies and
known api's known approaches right a lot
of developers probably have you know
used EE technologies at some point in
their career right they probably know
what Jax or essa is what CDI is in a
servlet technology there's a lot of
things out there JP AAA for persistence
that all comes from enterprise Java and
that you can just you know continue to
use in such a modern approach and what I
always would like to focus on is what
solves business problems right that's
the beauty of that approach you actually
you code your business solution in Java
you coat that in java classes right as
you always did and then you just add
some annotations and that's basically
you know the description what your
runtime should do and that's pretty much
it right so it's not very heavy it's
literally just a few some few
annotations comment like structures that
add to your code that then you can you
can use there I think the combination of
Jakarta and micro profile is really
great for you know modern approaches
there so if you look into this
technologies there are some runtimes out
there that support well either 2/4 or
micro profile but I think for pragmatic
real world projects it makes sense to
you know use both technologies together
and open Livadia is one solution where
you can use that in combination and
other solutions are of Tomi Eve for
example or payara
a server or wide fly so these are all
and well runtimes that supports this
approach where I can just very quickly
and very productively write applications
modern applications to that you know
solve your problems they're also it's
quite interesting to have a look at that
if you work for an environment that has
existing investment in EE either if it's
the knowledge of developers you know who
just know how to use CDI jax-rs it makes
a lot of sense to just continue to use
that but please with a modern runtime
right that's the whole point or you even
have projects that were built originally
for ohm you know some more legacy
runtime
if you have projects that have been
built for an old WebSphere of an old
WebLogic and stuff like that you
definitely want to swap the runtime
right nobody wants to run that old that
old crap that just takes a half an hour
to startup right so they're much more or
modern runtimes out there today example
will open Liberty but since it's based
originally on the same API is on the
same technology there's a high chance
that you can reuse most of it without
you know migrating too much without
rewriting everything from scratch but if
you would choose a totally different
technology you know you migrate to a
different language even or to a
different enterprise framework well then
you definitely have to rewrite
everything from scratch right you have
to throw away all the code you have
because it's a different API but with
that approach there's a high chance that
even if you use some legacy stuff it is
still supported and the same is true of
course for the knowledge you have that's
actually much more important as a
developer to use these api's then
whatever what always helps them is to
keep the build simple that's why I
showed you such a simple docker file
three lines of code simple maven
approach without the plugin
configuration and whatever use the
conventions that are there might have a
look at the documentation of the build
tool convention of mailing faces and
things like that they are very
straightforward and you know you don't
have to add a lot of XML and stuff like
that if you keep that simple and of
course invest in testing and automation
and see ICD well that is always a good
idea right and that just enables you to
well ship your software with more with
more confidence and faster and with
quality being built in so I hope that
was a helpful overview for a modern way
how to build Enterprise Java
applications and I hope it was fun to
watch thank you very much for your
attention
[Applause]